نشرت إحدى مستشفيات أركنساس أحد أطبائها
تشارك ما يحدث بالفعل لأن
متغير دلتا يخترق
مجتمعه ،
ما أتمنى حقًا أن تراه
هو النظر في عيون أب شاب
أو رجل نبيل
يعرف أنه قد يكون
قصيرًا بالنسبة لهذا  العالم لأنهم لم
يحصلوا
على لقاحهم
والندم والندم
على وجوههم والخوف
من الطبيب يرسم أن الصورة المفجعة للدكتور
مايكل بولدن
ينضم إلي الآن دكتور بولدينغ أولاً وقبل كل شيء
شكرًا لك على كل ما قمت به
خلال هذا الوباء هنا نحن
مرة أخرى مع الحالات المتزايدة التي تكون فيها
في أركنساس
، أنت والأطباء والممرضات الآخرون مذهلون ،
نعلم أن هذا أصبح الآن وباءً من
غير الملقحين
أخبرنا بما تراه
كل
يوم وأنت تميل إلى هؤلاء المرضى جيدًا
شكرًا لك على استضافتي ، فأنا بالتأكيد
أمثل
الآلاف من العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية المتعبين جدًا ،
لقد جئت للتو من
غرفة مريض في العشرينات من عمره واستغرق الأمر
ستة أشخاص.  حاول وضعه في وضع الانبطاح
على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
ونرى أشخاصًا تتراوح أعمارهم بين 20 و 30 عامًا يموتون الآن من مرض يمكن الوقاية منه ومن المحزن أن نلاحظ أنك تعلم أنك لا تستطيع أن تكون بصحة جيدة بالنسبة لهذا الفيروس الذي نراه.  هذا
كروس فيت يوم الثلاثاء وعلى جهاز
التنفس الصناعي يوم الجمعة ، لا يمكنني الحصول
على ما يكفي مما
نراه هنا في هذه الوحدات ولكي أكون
واضحًا ، أعني أن هذا أمر محزن للغاية أنك
تغادر الغرفة للتو  يبلغ من العمر 20 عامًا
ويفعل ذلك 20 هل هذا الشخص
غير محصن ولديه كوبي فقط يريد أن
يكون واضحًا
نعم ، لقد غطت غير الملقحة
ولا توجد شروط موجودة مسبقًا
، وإلى الحد الذي يمكنك التحدث إليه مع
بعض هؤلاء الأشخاص ،
ماذا يقولون  لك من حيث
الأسف ، هل يتحدثون عن
المعلومات الخاطئة
التي دفعتهم إلى عدم الحصول على اللقاح ،
ما تسمعه منهم مباشرة
هذا صحيح تمامًا.
ميل  nority المضادة للقاحات تمامًا
وما اكتشفته منذ
نشر هذا الفيديو هو أنه كان لدي
عشرات الأشخاص شخصيًا ويسأل المئات في
جميع أنحاء المستشفى
الآن عن اللقاح وأعتقد أن
هناك المزيد من الأشخاص الموجودين على
الحياد ونوع من  المنطقة الرمادية التي
لديها أسئلة مناسبة ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو السبب في أنك رأيت
ارتفاع معدل التطعيم لدينا في أركنساس
في الأسبوع الماضي لأن الناس
يطرحون أسئلة مناسبة
ونحاول إيصال الرسالة
إليك ولكني أرى
شخصًا ما يوميًا  على مدى الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية ، من
المحتمل أن يكون الموت بالتأكيد
مريضًا
جدًا ويسأل عما إذا كان بإمكانهم الحصول على لقاحهم
ومن المحزن أن يخبرهم
أن هذا الوقت قد
مضى منذ خمسة إلى ستة أسابيع لمنع ذلك